[Music]
why try to act like you did like I
played the piano this is rod Simba he's
a he's a loyal listener and he's the
music producer and he said I want to
make you a beat and he made me a beat
that's how we work here this is a 33% so
what I was actually talking to Gabe
who's a production guy here and it's
funny because every person that comes on
that hears the music is like once the
freestyle like it just happens like
Martellus Bennett on Monday he couldn't
help himself he just went yeah in fact
at the end of the episode another one of
the 33% of listeners literally freestyle
over the beat and they sent it in and
I'm gonna play that at the end it's
really really good the voice you're
hearing right now is a mad a bunch of
clay New York Jets got the steel of the
offseason a two-time Pro Bowler and all
pro a Super Bowl champion and he's
sipping coffee kolache o Semele how you
doing bro welcome to New York appreciate
it appreciate you knew my name when you
walked in which felt pretty [ __ ] good
I mean life you're kind of popular if
you haven't notice really
you've seen my [ __ ] yeah everybody and
the one I really want to say though is
ebo Quinn oh oh oh you know okay I just
know that Nyjah listen no I look at this
one so you want to earn my favor early
on the show so you are ebo for people
that don't understand EBU
is a tribe in Nigeria yeah my fiance's a
baby oh oh yes that's like one of the
smaller Church super small but I can't
believe that your mom let you not be a
doctor or a lawyer like finessed I was
like yeah look I promise I'm gonna get a
scholarship imma get a scholarship she
was like you you have the arrogance to
think that with these statistics and the
odds that you can be a
you an athlete and she would like go
online and like print it out I'm like oh
she would show you people so like a lot
of people I think think I've said this
about Asian parents Jewish parents I'm
learning that Nigerian parents are the
most intense of them se mueve so I am an
extreme underachiever in my community to
write of three girls yeah so like all
the pressure is on the baby yeah what we
needed a z' on every test well so I kind
of slid a little bit because like I had
an older sister I was kind of like a
little wild so like as long as I bawled
and got like B's A's and I was straight
like I didn't get my act right really
until junior senior year I think I like
slid out with like that three six or
something I feel but I mean you were
like three time on it took me a while
though yeah it took me awhile like my
first couple years I go I'm not gonna
lie like freshman year I think sophomore
year I might have like had like a seer
or something like this oh yeah went out
what's funny is a lot of the listeners
right now like you're a football player
you're allowed to get C's not if you're
Nigeria you said that you're your lesser
like do you still get told like your
friend just became a doctor like did
oh yeah well mainly now it's like
marriage like why are you no I'm married
like everybody's getting married why are
you not married why are you not a pastor
why you're not a doctor like why are you
doing these things yes I guess I'm just
a bad kid right like NFL player like
signed the biggest contract ever when it
happened like but no look at that stuff
but I'm realizing like you're from
Houston there's a huge Nigerian
contingent in Houston I didn't even
realize that but there's been some great
Evo's Nnamdi Asomugha Zebo Osio and
Europe Prince Amukamara like and now I'm
also realizing you're practically like
the New York Nyjah right now like you
Quincy a new noix and you just strapped
in the third round chumma Doga like it's
a super wave five people are there like
scouts are like realizing it leo they're
kind of athletic yes
well I mean and look it's all sports
like a mecca Okafor Plus
you get to rock the green and white yeah
that's dope out there why that's so on
so that's like our dungeoneering like
flag that's like our colors so I mean we
all know it was like 94 I think we were
like in the World Cup or something like
you just got it last year yeah yeah yeah
but I mean we did I think we actually
did well when I was like a kid but
gotcha but now I remember that been one
of my earliest memories African
Christian Fellowship like it's like the
church you go to after you go to the
first church right and you're there it's
like 4 p.m. Wow but yeah like you see
those colors everywhere there's a lot of
like pride and stuff so oh my god yeah
those colors and obviously the Jets were
my first team and I was like in third
grade
oh really yeah yeah do you think it was
we were decide we were the cypher Jets I
don't know why but we were that was like
that was my first team we bought two I
grew up I was on the Royals and like I
just love the Royals for a little bit
because that was my little league
baseball team was the Royals so you were
actually on the Jets as a kid I used to
trace like Jets players like at the
library like race I should know his name
I should know his name but he's number
eight he's like that short for bet yeah
him yeah yeah I used to trace him cuz he
was on the cover of some book when I was
in elementary school like you're on
fourth grade you know you have like a
little book fair it is scholastic he was
on the book fair and I'll say like
snapjet
I mean I'm playing for the Jets I used
to like because I was a terrible artist
I used to have to put the paper down and
then over it just trace it and I look at
my work like yeah it's gonna be me dude
Scholastic Book Fair was the single
greatest thing ever and I look back I
used to buy the dumbest computer games
like Castle take over and I'd come home
be like the book fairs the [ __ ] like I
thought you're the one guy that went to
the book friend and get a book where you
I got some books I was trying to get
yeah I was trying to get the computer
games like I was I was trying to play
some [ __ ] and I loved books because of
Pizza Hut because of book it were you
read a certain amount of books and you
got a free personal pan piece we did rad
dart rap target read a book do a report
get a buck it's wrapped argument yeah
yeah I was wrecking up that wasn't
wrecking up dude I was at Pizza I used
to go to the library and just fill the
page
books that I've never read just to get
personal pan pizzas yeah I was a piece
of [ __ ] they would they would check you
know our school they make you do yeah
they're like lefke you read war and
peace you're in the third I had a auntie
that literally would like you couldn't
even play outside until you like read a
book you go sleep over and I didn't have
any brothers so I'd hang out with my
cousins and I'd please can I sleep over
only to remember on Saturday you must
read a book ooh read a book and do a
report once you go home what you
literally would have to do wall sits if
you like tried to fake it like forever
you'd be sitting there and that's why
when you said earlier they're just
realizing that Nyjah has incredible
athletes this last year I've obviously
been more attuned to it because of my
relationship the Nigerian bobsled team
the jerseys for the Nigerian football
team the the that were a soccer team
were incredible like that took over
everywhere I see all these major
athletes it does feel like a movement to
be a part of that movement
what kind of pride does that give you
it's pretty cool man it's pretty cool
cuz it's like it's weird cuz it's like I
feel like when I was growing up I didn't
really see a lot of other Nigerian like
players like the neighborhood I grew up
in it was kind of a stale like there
wasn't a lot of like Nigerians it was
just like like black kids and then just
me you know I mean and then and the
cultures are very different very very
different people to understand that I
know it's night and day difference so I
wasn't even like I couldn't even really
move like I didn't really fit in yeah I
mean so it's like yeah there's there's
and plus you're in Houston and which is
like a melting pot of like a million
different cultures and then you're being
put in with African American and you're
like no Nigerian is its own it's so
unique and you only saw your people when
you went to church on the saw floor so
that's like the only time you saw your
people other than that if you're on the
northwest you were just as yes we're by
ourselves
I'm so you doing what so they can get
money poured on me and my way you know
about the dance so much just feel I have
to see videos of that oh when I get the
official and I think we're gonna where a
rapper yes
and we're gonna do green and white -
because I'm an Eagles fan
the other team that has those Gunners so
I'm just gonna tell my dad no it's
Eagles color so I'll be like great
sounds good
best jollof rice in the world
my mom's obviously my mom makes the best
jollof actually my boy
Jeremy Zoot all he was my senator and
[Music]
he's gone in and so we have this there's
the bad the jollof rice war is like my
mom and his mom like who makes the best
law and I was just over like you know
his his mom sauce or whatever you know
and then with another one of my team
people don't realize so jollof what
would you say jollof is the most popular
food in in nigeria I would probably say
pounded yam like fufu goosey soup but
explain to people why jollof rice is
such a big deal to the Nigerian culture
I think because rice like the grain
itself is just like obviously it's like
cheap and sustainable like yes you know
it's you can eat a lot of it's delicious
and it's amazing it's just good
so Nigerians and Ghanaians fight a lot
about who has the best jollof and for my
personal experience it seems very common
to see that conversation happening
between guy names and I hate it a lot
yeah I've had Ghanaians in this office
come up to me and say I'm gonna make you
jollof and prove to you that it's better
than I jeera rice is all sort though and
it's just not as good like the open of
spice in it and I told my fiancee and
she was like don't even eat it it's so
weird how like it's similar but it's so
different and then fufu sounds
interesting
pounded yam but it's like a it's super
thick and it's like it's like a way I
describe it to people that have never
like seen it before it's like basically
very firm moldable mashed potatoes
that's how I like to describe her like
this way yeah like play-doh basically I
won over do you eat it I love I love
food that's my favorite dish
like my mom will freeze it and said I
said if you're trying to lose weight you
can't eat fufu it's definitely not Kido
yeah but my mom like there's like
healthy ways to do it like they do like
there's like a like a flower not flower
oh no like there's like you know like
Vanessa it like the reason I friend I
won over her family because I ate
foo-foo because she had told me
beforehand what kind of soup what I'll
say what was the first one on a suit
whoa no what was the first soup you said
earlier a bono or a GU see it was like a
it was a vegetable super cooked I think
there may have been some fish in it it
sounds like it was probably okra it's
okra soup vegetables in it it was what I
think was one of the first ones you said
maybe you gu see what color was it
brown brown yeah it had to rip it and
then roll it yeah so I did and as soon
as I did that they're like oh do what to
do and then I dipped it in and they're
all like this and I said hey can I have
some of the fufu and none of the kids
really eat it a lot and her brother
leaned in and goes you don't have to do
this it's so good I don't know so I went
in there and I took the first one I was
like this is amazing and I had like I
had like three or four and her uncle
Samson walks up to me and shakes my head
and goes you're part of the family now
and I was like I just ate my way in this
family did it but I I just I when I saw
that you were Nigerian that your ebo I
was like I want to talk about this
because I think it's it's it's such an
interesting and cool culture and I think
it's it probably has to define so much
of who you are yeah and people people
don't even know that about you I would
think they know that you're not yeah
yeah yeah that's true I mean I feel like
if they want to know and they talk to
you they'll figure it out pretty quick
yeah but what do you think about this
that's I saw that you just went to China
and Japan yeah I mean could you even
walk down the street without getting
photos taken of you so it's weird like
my boy Jeremy went a few years before I
did
he said they yeah and they took a lot of
pictures of him but when I went it was
like cool it was like super on if they
got used to it or what they'd bust them
yeah it was odd that didn't happen at
all
what was your journey what did you want
to see what did you do so I went to Art
Basel in Hong Kong which was amazing saw
some really good art partied a lot
obviously like it doesn't shut down what
is the party like so yeah this is like I
forget the name of it but there's like a
big strip of bars where there's like
literally like six level places Wow and
it's just like there's rooftop spots
that look over the entire city there's
people from all over the world or it's a
fight kind of like you know a good major
financial hub so and they drink right
yeah they drink they go out late there's
like after-party spots that I went to I
mean I should I literally keep notes on
my phone but I want to like slow down
but like I literally write everything
down really yeah I keep a travel journal
nice somebody's want me to do that when
I was in Italy I don't exactly
especially when there's drinking
involved so yeah so you're like drunk at
a Hong Kong party rating in the Notes
app yeah yeah or the next day I'll be
like yo it was that spot we went to and
then then already done then I do that
sometimes too like if I kick it with
some people that I'm like I can't
believe I'm kicking it with as soon as I
get home if I'm a little bit drunk or
whatever I raked out everything because
the next day I want to remember it I
don't want to be like so I just one time
with Kenyon Martin and it was I don't
know I always remember what happened to
what I did I just remember the name of
places so now I went to a Michelin star
restaurant in a subway station and it
was the best dumplings I ever had in my
life but I just don't remember tell me
it was here in tongfu or something I
think it might have been called and then
I went to a spot called holy fook that
was really holy I went to a lot of dope
like really good like this the food is
just like crazy
I'm a big dump well I am now it's funny
cuz I wasn't before until no actually
I'm that's what I'm going like tonight
I'm going to do Jalan oh really dude you
want
okay yeah I'm getting dumpling that's
where they just like go around with the
carts
and you're like I'll take 17 of those
it's a nicer place it's like a little
bit more upscale kind of dimly lit but
they bring out like those the little
wooden things of dumplings and they're
just as good they have like the super
ones when you bite into it I like savory
is like ah like is so what was what's
the difference between China and Japan
because I would argue that probably a
lot of my listeners haven't been to
either
I feel like Japan was more laid-back
like it felt like slower people were
like wait well not way nicer but just
like they're nice in both places but you
could definitely tell like you know
bowing a lot and like just like greeting
you and just smiling or that happened a
lot instead of pictures there's a lot of
smile it's like yeah are you different
like that's like super friendly super
curious you know like an old lady on the
on the like trying to get up the
escalator though like pick her up and
like wow you know like it's yeah it's so
cool cause like it's similar to Nigerian
cultures so it's like so refreshing to
see that like I didn't realize about age
and rank until I went and celebrated
Christmas was Christmas my Christmas
with my fiance and they were like like
the young kids are like going around and
doing everything and I was like I can't
tell them what to do and they're like no
that's like part of the girl it's so
true
you'll literally find yourself sprinting
up stairs just to hand you're your mom
and dad to remote well you were the
frickin youngest one too right you like
you literally would run up there and be
like but you can't say anything he's
like it's right there that's why you
take coaching so well that's true that's
true actually you know because I mean
I'm not gonna lie I've definitely had
some things coached to me where it's
like that would never work in a game and
it has to be repeated over and over
again to the point where it's like
you're literally teaching me bad habits
and then I'll say something yes no but
that's you just put up with it because
you're like okay I put up with it a lot
it's almost bad cuz then it gets to a
point where it's like where did that
explosion come from and it's like dude
you've been telling me to do the wrong
thing for like hey yeah I had Bart Scott
in here and he was talking about when
Mike Singletary was coaching
and they had some guys on that Ravens
defense that just don't hold their
tongue and they're like nope coach
you're wrong yes whatever like he came
back in he was like like freaking out
because the Ravens are like nah bro you
got to deal with us yeah yeah yeah see I
wouldn't do well with that but
definitely I let a lot of things slide I
would say but then when it's to the
point where it's to my detriment or like
the other guys detriment especially if
I'm looking around and I have guys
complaining a lot to me in the locker
room and stuff then it's just like hey
man we gotta figure this it happens I
mean look not everyone's perfect like
I'm sure Belichick is coming on a Monday
and been like I [ __ ] up sorry about
that you know what I mean yeah it
happens but the bad habit stuff
offensive line coaches in general I
think it's one of the most interesting
positions in sports it's so late they're
the weirdest coaches ever like what is
your experience bin with offensive line
coaches so they usually have really big
egos you know you usually have really
really big egos I don't know why that is
do they harp on the guys that they've
built in the past yeah they do and the
weird thing is like for the most part
the guys I talk about you know like
right out of college they're already
really talented so you're just like yeah
[Music]
it's like okay yeah he was gonna do that
himself no matter what or like even you
you know I mean like you go to Baltimore
and like right away it's like just
because nfl.com said that you needed
more coaching doesn't mean that that was
the truth yeah you learned so much more
just by watching other players and then
you also have to learn how to adapt it
to your game I feel like where your guys
get too caught up it's like especially
when they're on the fringe or they're
free agents they try to do every little
detail and they overthink things but
it's like you're an athlete you can play
football you would not be here if you
can't play football and so just take a
deep breath relax take the parts that
actually work use it the stuff that
doesn't work for you throw it out and
write to me it kind of feels like you're
you're gaining the Infinity stones like
Avengers to where it's like okay I'm
really good against the bulrush I figure
that out I got that down okay now I'm
gonna work on the spin only out like all
likes that stuff
we're on there work on my own punch and
you just kind of pick
stop number years deal what you can yeah
and you sir of you stolen from so
definitely I'll actually say a coach
that I've actually stolen from Juan
Castillo there's some things that he
taught me that actually so yes I'm not
even gonna like yeah cuz it's a secret
but there's some things secret that he's
that he's taught that they actually work
I just don't I don't use it all the time
like wow but like yeah there's
definitely some things where he can take
the thinking out of it if you set a
certain way and then like as far as like
punching and stuff that's that's pretty
unique to me like I like to like you
know like mess around and stuff I don't
just I'm not a robot
three-punch like yeah do all that so
what do you do so it's a combination
between a want conceal set an aggressive
kind of martial Yonder put my helmet in
there and then the arms the hands are
just me that's just reaction in you
that's just actually I kind of just like
to mess with the defender like I what
don't want him to know when I'm gonna
punch them is that a really strong punch
and I just wanted him to be like wary of
it sometimes I won't even punch like
sometimes it'll be so like wondering
what I'm gonna do that I just end up
just grabbing him and you just kind of
hold that hit so which is your better
punch hand I usually punch with my left
cuz I'm a left guard right and have a
7-foot sue wingspan and one arm is
longer than two as you know if you've
ever like yeah you just you kind of like
put that arm out there and you had they
have to they have to respect it that's a
do they you have to swat it out the way
they have to respect it because your
arms are so long literally that right
went out of their stances in their face
already so they're like they have to
deal with that first I'll let him deal
with that and then I'll like I usually
jab them with my right yeah I saw you
have 35 and 7/8 arms like that's insane
bro I use that to my advantage
yes yeah huit so it's a cat-and-mouse
game the whole time but you being at
guard I have to imagine you you're
dealing with stunts now the big thing in
the NFL is third downs we're moving a
pass rusher to inside yeah have you seen
that trend the last few years I've seen
that since I was a rookie the Steelers
were doing that forever like every time
we play the Steelers whether it was like
playoffs or whatever it was
like those are big rivalry games they
did whatever they could to like get to
the quarterback yeah
I saw guys dancing linebackers dancing
in there every time we played the Texans
like those guys - he's just dancing
around like messing around and stuff but
like I feel like a lot of teams are
definitely starting to do that [ __ ] man
it's true because I think a trick with
that is just tell me just to get back if
you get back you can see everything like
if you you know the snap counts or get
off the ball right vertical like you
have to set like a tackle um yeah and
get straight back you can see what he's
gonna do and the more him or he dances
the better it is for you like let him
dance all day and then kill him when you
can when he gets close enough what is
the time in which you got somebody with
the punch and you think it's your number
one punch like ko serious bro
there is one where it was kind of like a
punch off of a Boris Musa so it's a
Samoan dude from the Panthers she's not
yeah yeah yeah yes so he Boris me it was
more like a drop I got anchored like I
did like a sumo yeah and then I like
gathered all my strength and I literally
just tossed them on the top of his head
like he went all the way back in flipped
well I was so int oh so yeah yeah I was
a good battle that was a good battle it
was a dog so is that something we're
like you get into the locker room and
like the next day or not the locker room
like you're watching film and they're
just replaying it over and over again or
you like perk up in your seat when you
know that play is coming it's not cool
you get a self suck fine if you get to
hype on your own place what its kind of
have to like play it cool and just sip
your coffee and then like your turban it
really see much like a solid play selfs
look fine like if you brag or if you get
hype on your own play like a pancake or
whatever you get fined is this every
locker room you've been in its most yeah
I mean if not an actual fun in Oakland
that was an actual fine but in Baltimore
it was just like a come on be humble
yeah yeah so I was like yeah exactly so
it's like you can get caught you can
kind of shake your head that was like
the cool thing to do
like a wide receiver room dude the whole
room going crazy over yes shut this
[ __ ] down quarterback oh yeah
yeah yeah I said quarterback I was like
what they watching you're like yeah that
is exactly like that but on the inside
they're like what is do you believe that
there's different personalities between
different positions on the o-line
positions on the old line like is there
a difference like our left is a certain
way our centers a certain way not not
not all the way across the board like
there's some left tackles that are
aggressive and can like jump you and are
strong and then there's like finesse
ones so there's like some finesse guy
Jason Peters can dance
anybody can do he can be do both that's
why he's a Hall of Fame he's just rare
die like Tyron Smith that's one of the
examples of a coach one used to talk
about Jason B and you'd be like Dawg but
the way he said that he learned like hit
that technique to teach other guys I
will say he did admit was by watching
Peters well he's obviously not left foot
and he doesn't he literally just watched
him like how is he every time and then
he figured out patterns for certain
players and then he like which I respect
that cuz then it kind of makes it didn't
work every time of course cuz obviously
guys are instinctive they can feel that
you're in a certain position every
single time so obviously they're gonna
do something about that right but like
definitely when you're tired and it's
the fourth quarter there are certain
sets that will put you in the best
possible position to succeed I'm just
like I think about von Miller's got his
pass rushing camp I had Trent Brown in
here and Trent was the only offensive
lineman that went to that camp and he
even told me that it was great because
he saw their moves and it held like he's
like I'm learning what their favorite
moves are and I'm hearing Vaughn talk
about you know I can't do this it's the
Von Miller pass rush you can't he fights
he invites all the other good passers
just why would I why would he let
alignment in bro
Trojan horsing I think that I think the
offensive linemen need to get together
like I think we're doing one in Dallas
are you doing yeah who you with Brian
actually is the one that invited me
Brian winners yeah but I can't remember
off the top of my head ear out of a sack
mark should be there he's like there
he's going like Brandon Brooks should be
there like I'm just gonna guards yonder
you know what I mean like probably but
it's so much more valuable to you guys
at your position because who cares if
the guard on the other team does great
really what happened to yeah if he's
great then he might get paid more so
that when you're up for the contract
again the levels and I also think that
offensive line play is kind of taking a
step back the last few years
whether it's like spread offenses in
college football have kind of made it
harder or there's just I guess I would I
feel like personally this is what I see
I feel like it's not as nasty as it used
to be it's not as physical as it used to
be you know I'm not seeing you guys
fallin on people anymore it's so weird
like the stuff that they're just like
teaching now it's good to teach like
technique but I don't know it's not to
say it's because it's become technique
for them it's very it's always been a
little technique driven but usually like
you'd have a coach that's like bury em
like you know like in his head yeah
finish him take a soil from like fourth
quarter he doesn't want to play be
physical like be physical that I was
like the way that I was coached from
like basically my whole life until like
the last probably the first time that
change would probably be with cable but
like yeah I don't know I don't know like
being physical it's like the most
important aspect yeah you still need
technique but I don't know it's all
about like keep your head out and like
you want to lift them and like foot for
foot for foot for foot for foot far and
you're like be true to keep your feet
flat on the ground
let me just punch him in the chest and
it's like bro like football is a
passionate game you do need those tools
but at the end of the day it's a
passionate gag when you're not huh
when do you think you learned that like
the Bennets of fashion is getting past
the game college because
I was at Iowa State you know I was a
two-star whatever had a big chip on my
shoulder and I knew I could ball like I
went there because okay I didn't get
recruited by Texas we're playing Texas
beat Texas for the first time in school
history oh we're playing Nebraska Sue's
over there all right cool like they're
supposed to win the national
championship beat them at home first I'm
just like the 70s
okay Oklahoma State's coming in here
they're ranked number two in the country
triple overtime we ran the same play
like three times in a row beer and power
they still can stop it and it was
passion it was senior night moms in the
stands it's not going down like that I'm
not going out like that y'all are going
home we're going to a ballgame it's
passionate that's amazing that's another
thing that's funny is I think there was
a game like two years ago
2016 when you had the incredible season
and I think you guys beat a team you ran
the same run play like 20 times in a
game yeah like that's what's so funny
about the NFL all sports
oh so dope because nobody nobody knows
like even between the guys you don't
talk about it they might tell their
homie like that either d-line they might
tell their home you know like he real
you know but it'll never ever come out
but it's literally a one-on-one boxing
match at that point like literally
fourth quarter overtime whatever that
situation is when the game is on the
line or when it's that moment where it's
literally like a dogfight like y'all
aren't even talking [ __ ] at this point
like it's literally just you and him and
like it becomes a dogfight and those are
the best and then and the best
coordinators can see like they see the
matchups and they can see like yeah yeah
so they'll keep running it like he's in
the zone right now like keep running
that play like he's got the head and the
dopest thing about it is like being in
the huddle and you hear it again you
like ya [ __ ] with me like let's go Keo
just hit his chest so hard that he
knocked the sign off that's awesome
really well done I appreciate that
energy bring your 33% but that but
that's so interesting because I've never
thought of an offensive lineman hearing
his number called
you know what I mean usually it's like
we're looking for this wide receiver on
the go
we're pounding the rock again but also
it's like oh you're coming to the left
side again you know
you know you know like the mostly will
ever get is like I remember like looking
at DP and we would just like dap like
yeah why we're 2016 season of you Donald
Penn and Hudson Center left guard left
half I don't forget gay bro I'm I'm not
messing game go to Mississippi and hunt
- yeah dog straight dog you went to
school with uh we when you're destroying
people what does that feeling like it's
like it's the best it's the best feeling
and and the best feeling about it is
everybody feeds off of it like I'm
talking about said the robbers we're on
at white hours all right dog like he'll
just get this look in his eye and then
you'll get like a run around the corner
like perimeter and sets got his dude out
of bounds like cuz he yeah he sees you
and then like DP will see me get a
Kingsley alright and then Gabe will see
me get a cake alright how many you got
we get back to the roots Ali and
pancakes like it just becomes a
competition within the competition
everybody's just feeding off each other
like you see a guy bury somebody like on
your lawn you just get so height and the
energy changes it goes from like Oh
again the X's and O's it literally like
that goes out the window at a certain
point when you're rolling like it
doesn't matter what play you call that's
what's so funny is with like analytics
and people looking at like play calling
and stuff now at the end its are your
big people gonna be their big people
sometimes it's just that simple
like I mean I'm not throwing analytics
out there I'm sure there's coverages and
things I don't know about all that yeah
but like literally you can try to like
look at analytics and numbers but when
there's some other [ __ ] going down
during a game like bro you can't measure
that you can't it all comes down alright
that's why when I make my predictions in
beginning of the year one of the main
things I look at other than quarterback
and coach because that to me is always
going to be the same depth on the O line
and D line not just who are your best
five and your best for on defense that's
true who is your eight who is your eight
on offense who are your swing tackles
who's your who's your into your because
it's true someone's gonna get hurt yeah
it's a [ __ ] hard game but if I see
your ten deep on the D line and ten deep
on the O line bro you're gonna be good
that's dangerous Raiders o line was deep
when you're on the
even's that ravens o-line was - [ __ ] no
hold the whole team was d that was
unbelievable
blasters safeties corners Oh lime I'll
probably say online wasn't as deep
actually well I would say the fact that
you had to come in as a rookie second
round pick and start at right tackle
yeah no no you see you see that right
tackle then they moved me to guard left
never played that position in my entire
life but you had to come in and you
started every game at right tackle yeah
to start your career like that right
away I mean it had to make you some of
the man you are today just to get
dropped in like that it said a lot about
like my my the work that I put in in
college like all the games that I
started in college like my attitude my
demeanor in college
left tackle college and just like that
whole the way that I worked I literally
in my mind was profession already in
college the way that I prepared like the
way that I trained I was like I'm doing
this I was literally all in chance my
major I'm like I'm focusing on ball I'm
doing this just felt it was literally
like just all in this is what I want to
do I'm going for it if I don't make it
I'm gonna make it I'm going for it and
so like that it just felt like that all
paid off til I come in and get and get
the job like that like so I actually
called me to report early horrible and
I'm literally I can call it so like just
graduate whatever and he's like yeah we
need you to come in a few weeks early
like or one of our tackles is overweight
or whatever right now we need you to
like we're in the players whatever so I
come in early like I'm learning to play
a book like I'm lifting like a grind and
I'm like y'all like I think I'm gonna
get a shot you know what I mean and I
still remember like that first preseason
game in Atlanta first NFL game I've ever
been to walking in there looking at the
jumbo trying to be a my girl like I'm in
the NFL right now like and Flacco be a
my alright let's go you're not a rookie
anymore in my call in the play and be
like crazy first play was a good play -
I don't remember I think it was I know
my first win College was not I buried
the guy and got a [ __ ] flag I was
pissed I did my job who was there a guy
that lined up opposite you that rookie
year that was your oh [ __ ] I'm in the
NFL moment
cuz you were lining up against terrell
suggs in practice yeah I guess that's
probably why I think I just saw like
blocking so many like different guys
especially when I moved to guard and I
was blocking Haloti Ngata like it was
just so much talent that and they grind
it like they worked hard that's like
where I got like kind of how you prepare
as a pro like your attitude like every
rep matters in practice like that
attitude like there's even you know
there's some times where you you know
guys on the other side of the ball will
be annoyed that you're like work ethic
like come on make through the season but
like that's where I saw like how you
need to prepare to win a championship
was by being on that lining and going
against that D line like in blocking
guys like Chris canny yeah what I mean
like it's like then when you get on the
field on Sunday it's like who are you
gonna block that you're even worried
about I think my first I think my first
one of my first starts in was in the
regular season one of my might one of
the biggest guys remember blocking and
being like what was DeMarcus Ware like I
was like you know what like everybody
like everybody's like so worried and
then I remember being moved to guard and
they were worried about Justin Smith and
I'm like what do you know what are y'all
talking about like because like the way
that I prepared in my tenacity
I was just prepared like I was ready
similar skill set I think at that point
of their careers DeMarcus Ware and I I
feel like DeMarcus at that point when
you play there are more physical guys I
don't think anyone's get out physical
you yeah I know who were the kind of
guys though that like give you like a
little bit the smaller guys player that
I have ever played against his Aaron
darling he's actually they and you know
you know it's true when guys actually
see it cuz we're very prideful so you
but you know he's straight like you know
he's nice but like when you're just like
you know like he's clearly when you
separate somebody from other players
that's like was the first moment were
you even like watching the film being
like I can handle this and get on the
field and it surprised you I'm not even
gonna lie I didn't really watch film
before I played him because I was just
like I'm gonna get in this head and play
physical like that was like my that's
exactly what I did you could watch the
film oh you beat him up no no sacks no
pressures but he was still the best guy
ever
still the best guy ever face has how
many times have you face them
um I think just that one time Wow you
know what you sound like right now
do you ever seen the clip of matumbo
telling Jordan you've never dumped on me
before
and he's like you've never gotten me you
know and joints like okay and then later
that season Jordan dunked on them I need
to see if you're playing now I'm just
gonna watch film to to win a Super Bowl
your rookie year now you're seven years
in a eight years in what kind of
perspective is that for you compared to
other players so that really taught me a
lot about what a locker I'm supposed to
look like and I just remember that
feeling that energy like the young guys
really talking the old guys really
talking to the young guys like we have a
commensurate system like every single
veteran had a young player like a rookie
and you're responsible for him like if
you got someone out on the weekend you
made sure he got home safe like you
taught him about off the field stuff
like professionalism and how you handle
your business it was just it was a
brotherhood and so I'm really grateful
that that was my first experience in the
NFL because like other guys that I came
in with I remember like I think some
guys were with like st. Louis like man
they so petty Brody like women bro like
it's like quicksand stuff like and I'ma
be like man I'm glad I don't have to
deal with that [ __ ] like but like
our locker room was just like so tight
like everybody was just like they had
the same mission they everybody just was
focused on winning was that a horrible
thing or were there certain players that
I told them who's the players it was
like grey Lewis ed Reed ladarius Webb
but I just had leaders I forgot so your
first year you're with ed Reed and Ray
Lewis holy [ __ ] and Suggs Yonder Terrell
Suggs like Haloti Ngata and these guys
were just like men they were just like
leaders like they just were ambitious
they knew what they wanted to accomplish
wanted to take care of their families
like they just were focused like it was
just the men like the type of men that
were in that locker and they were just
men there was no like BS like they knew
what they wanted to get done you've
experienced BS sense I'm assuming
yeah all the time all the time I just
wish I had more of a personality to be
like those guys but I guess it's not my
personality dawg like I'm to live off a
slipper you don't seem like the Nigerian
in me I don't know but like I'm just
like not decide to be like oh like no
you know like I just feel like that's so
funny oh no God maybe I need to learn
how to be like that like don't do that
but it's just not like my natural thing
to tell people what to do I think you
know what you'll probably reach a point
like Ray did and Ed did where you know
that your windows really closing and you
realize that you can't put up with the
[ __ ] anymore
cuz your your birthdays when I turned 30
this year June 24 June 24th you're about
reaching the point of your life or
you're gonna be fed up with [ __ ] so
what's what's funny is like there's
definitely been some things that I have
seen when I first arrived but they're
already it seems like changing on one of
those is for sure like the work ethic
especially like the way guys are
grinding in OTAs right now on July on
yeah yeah yeah but like I feel like when
I first got there I kind of felt the
vibe like I was doing the most like
nobody ever say anything but there'd be
kind of like just that kind of energy
like all right am i doing too much you
know what I mean but like I feel like
now like dude we're grinded and it
didn't even take any conversation like
it just literally is just like happening
well you're gonna lead by example I feel
like that's just like I just I can't I'm
not a rah-rah
like guy like just see me bury somebody
and then go out there and do your thing
some people are built to be the stalkers
and also be the executors but that I
just think it takes so much energy to
speak something into existence and do it
it does you know because I almost feel
like you're taking energy away from the
actual action you know it's the same
reason that when I see an IPO like a
company go public or I see someone
announced they're shooting a movie and
they get all the comments
congratulations that you're doing a
great job and you haven't done anything
yet that's the part where I think people
can get caught up at the rah-rah go
search because you just you do the
rah-rah thing and you release some of
that you know you release that maybe you
hit the snooze from 550 to 555 it was a
great day yesterday
be super low-key though yeah you just
got to do the word every pause the enemy
uh you read the bug boot yeah Ryan
holiday yeah that's my guy no real gave
it to me
really yeah Java read obstacles the way
no that's the better one okay Ryan
holiday obstacles the way same guy
yes that's we I've had him on the show
multiple times that's pretty good dude
he's the man he's got another book if
because I know you meet with like
Silicon Valley people perennial seller
is an amazing book to perennial sellers
about he studies organizations and
groups that have lasted for like a long
time and what did they do to establish
that early on how does how does try
think I'm not Walmart but like a company
that's like a pizzeria that's been
around for a hundred years what do they
do that the pizzeria that was around for
six didn't do little stuff like that
looking at businesses and Apple and [ __ ]
it's the same thing what you're saying
it's foundation technique like the
people that are too heavy on one side
and they're not balanced yeah it will
eventually come back as sure you have to
have your own special ingredient and and
good intention in New Yorker in the
world wow I've been so like some I was
want to talk you that was a call he went
to Rome and all that sorry Ronnie but ya
know that's yeah Peter to me is not one
of those foods where I want you to study
the Masters I need an old grandmom that
has a sauce that she hasn't shared the
recipe that's a very nice thing though
like get it perfect that's what they do
with birth perfect every that's what
they do a sushi
oh yeah even like their French cuisine
in specific the most Michelin stars
created this guy and they're and French
is about perfection and yet here they
are
yeah because every day that's like the
ninja philosophy how do you feel about
France best experience cuz I didn't
speak any like that they did not like
that it's funny cuz I always give
cultures a chance that's the one place
I've traveled all over the road Africa
Iceland New Zealand Wow Japan China
Australia like I've been around and
that's one place where like bro what's
up what show me like what's up which are
so French much more rude than New
Yorkers it's not even close I don't even
know what they're like um let me stop
well I'm just curious what is rude in
France I've never been but I've heard
that like I don't know like ask somebody
for directions or something like that or
you know about like a dish on the menu
or like where to go out or the whole
wood heaters route yeah oh my gosh chefs
chefs and waiters like if you don't like
something and you sent it back I had a
friend do that while we were there and
it was an uproar like I couldn't even
tell my city chill dude so like he was
pissed but I was just laughing like I
love awkward situations like that I will
never send back a dish I did like no
that's what you order
but tell me the scene because I love
situations okay so what happened was we
had told him how beef tartare is were
like yo you've never had it you should
try over here try it yeah and you know
he's like a guy from like the Midwest or
whatever like what's his weird cuz he
likes he'll eat a steak rare but that
just the presentation in general I don't
know I will say that it was very blocky
like he just came out of like a span can
the presentation wasn't the greatest but
yeah he just wasn't feeling it he took a
bite and usually nod like can you like
at least like heat it up a little bit or
something up tartar and dude like
actually I will say I tried it and it
was actually fire like we almost
invented a dish like they literally just
like flame torch it for like a few
seconds and brought it back and it was
like completely different but like oh my
gosh like that dude was so mad like the
chef wants to talk to you
blah blah blah beef tartare is not
heated it's not cooked the chef came out
yeah like they were Pierce we literally
just like stopped by a place cuz like we
start our bags and stuff before we
checked in and they were lighting
like literally AXA dude if you like oh
like one of my friends why did they hit
a blind and the dude was like no like
like tripped on it and it was like the
wheels like dude like my boys like I'll
pay you and like this too but yeah like
wow like so weird like why though I
remember somebody like we were to like
this like place to drink that's nice
like there's like a really traditional
and like cool nice whatever is that yeah
might be place to go and my boy orders a
drink and the bartender was rude and he
makes a comment about it and the lady
next to us it's like we're talking about
how Russia wasn't there it was like
people not really tuned in America are
they nice all the time and we're like
that's not the point like we're paying a
lot of money to be here and yeah I've
never heard people in the service would
you let somebody just like slap you
because the place is nice you got to be
loving New York then I Love New York
it's awesome I love it so when you where
were you and you found out you were
being traded so this is gonna sound
super corny but what my mom would love
it I literally was coming out of church
[Laughter]
this is Church Howard Thurman Church of
All Souls I randomly started reading
about him after him okay and I was like
curious like because there was like a
lot of stuff going on in San Francisco
it was dough so they do like a lot of
like really cool cultural stuff yeah and
so I'm Irene about Howard Thurman I'm
like yeah like he kind of like
philosophy why's that we think about the
same think this is awesome so I'm like
well we thought of the church aw you're
like what that's lit I gotta go to it
how is nobody talking I like but you
know how they review stuff from Google
yeah nobody went and check them out like
all the times almost like fam every
single time I went it was like the most
it was actually like relevant to the
times and they're actually doing things
in the community culturally like they
literally had like a sermon stuff like
that
it was crazy like they're actually doing
things and it was just like well like
this church is awesome so yeah it was
like a Sunday and I you know I was going
to that church and Mayock like they
called me it was like you're like sorry
in every man I'm like actually we have I
was in there like working out and we had
a long conversation about your son's
friend but whatever it need to go I'm so
sorry I'm anyways going to New York
wait so mike Mayock said i've never met
you before completely forgot meeting me
in the conversation that we had about
meeting his son but it's all good
that's like I I was my first job was
supposed to be on nobody my first job
was supposed to be in Reno Nevada and
the news director got fired and the guy
that was filling in said listen Alex and
I was like mother [ __ ] so yeah that's
all did you have to leave church or were
you already walking outside I was
walking outside the funny thing is I was
walking in when he called and I actually
knew I had a feeling so I knew right
when I went in but also I dude this is
not gonna miss my vibe up and go into
church like whatever yeah I felt it I
knew I was like I'll call you back after
I get out oh you said that too yeah I
told him your phone wasn't buzzing you
weren't yeah no I had turned it off so
you turn it on any turning back on and
he calls me out goes hey sorry we never
met and you're like actually we have
yeah exactly
and then he was like yeah like I'm sorry
to say we've traded you to the Jets
whatever but like click whatever and
he's like Mike McKechnie is gonna call
you so Mike McCadden calls me and he's
like yeah man like I was you know over
in charge of scouting with the Houston
Texans and I've been looking at you
since I would say I remember having a
meet like we went really what's in the
Texans in us say man I'm watching like
trying to get you on the team one of the
first teams that wanted you when you
were going to Oakland you went to
Oakland oh yeah like keep the Texans
were like one of the people that come in
free agency were like I was like yeah
like yeah and then he was yeah it was
just like a really good conversation and
I was like yeah God's plan I actually
started playing cards playing oh so he
had on did you really drink
there probably was like two things
there's one that's like it's like the
highs and lows the low is the team that
I was just on training bled for that she
had so much pain for that like you vibed
so much with your teammates with I have
so many memories with like it was crazy
I remember hitting a gay Gabe's the
first person I told
he thought I was playing so I stopped
lying
yeah he was probably never know what
they've been doing around here like just
like that before you got traded they got
a Antonio Brown in a trade so you
probably funny yeah the funny thing was
the night before we were celebrating my
boy Neil his one of his friends like
started the company like startup or
whatever and we're celebrating her and
then the news came at dinner that we got
a B so we're all at the table I know we
bout to be cold like dang
and then like yeah the next exchange
yeah yeah it was the next day that's
real quick yeah but that's something you
have all these up and downs where you
have the up ABS on your team down the
team that I bled for and then up again
well I would say up again too cuz you
find out you're going to New York yeah
that too like what was it also the fact
that Mike like mckagan was like trying
to like get me over there so I'm like oh
so they really like me yeah and I kind
of felt like they didn't really [ __ ]
with us like with the whole crew and
like we're gonna dition they came in we
had like vibing bro we had a team at a
unit you know what I mean like similar
lock Berlin to Baltimore yeah and they
just like almost felt like rebuilding
right away like you could feel that
change in our member cable set me down
at the end line yeah man we don't take
this card if the cold indiana doesn't
take them out of out of quit nelson
we're gonna take him how do you feel
about moving to tackle like as soon as I
meet my first like one of the first
conversations I have you know what I
mean I want to be upfront and honest
with you which I respect him for that
but it was just kind of like yeah like
that our old line is cold though like
what like just the disrespect in general
just to be like yeah that's a thing
that's crazy to me is if you want to say
we're re-evaluating the wide receiver
position if you want to say we're gonna
look at running backs but when your
offensive line like three of them all
went to the pro ball the other two were
like really really solid and like
there's been no issues at all and to
just go we're gonna change that
foundation that was not the position
especially because we were like the
heart is working there's nothing that we
can do to convince you
it's deflating do you think they just
like why do you think they came in with
that mindset so from what I've heard
from other people it's kind of one of
those like ego things I guess somebody
was saying like oh like we're gonna win
a Super Bowl but it was with other
people's players so maybe he just wanted
to do it with his own guys this time I
don't know like I really don't know like
you never really know what's wrong with
him we had a lot of talks in his office
and they were not like what he said
obviously did not come to fruition so
take that for whatever it's worth what
was the best thing you were told that
didn't come to fruition yeah man the
next 5 years man like you're gonna be a
leader on this team we really respect
how hard you work in your work ethic and
all this and that like whoa man oh my
old partner Sims used to tell me all the
time that that cost Gruden a lot when he
was with the Bucs cuz he was a
quarterback on the boxes he would tell
you things and then later it wouldn't be
the truth and like I appreciate cable
telling you the truth
see I respect that yeah they're real he
did he kept it real it's like yes I a
man we're trying to make these moves
like we want to do what we wanted like
you know and it's like you know what's
up
you know I mean like you always at least
you know it's you might not like it but
you know it's damn that sounds like a
whole nother lesson learned for you this
whole problem a man like I played like I
went through the Coast Range with Gene
Chizik and then Paul Rhoads coming in
and hit me coming out in him being like
oh I'm telling ska so he has character
issues like all this others I've been
through so much like stupid political
like stuff then at this point it's just
like I almost expected out of coaches
especially because I'm the type of
player that I like to talk to the free
agents and stuff like that so I hear
things so I know yeah yeah I mean we
talked about so many people love to talk
about how like athletes can be childish
and I think coaches are worse what they
don't get drug tested they nothing like
nobody questions what they're doing like
they say a player's a certain way and we
take it we never wonder if a coach is a
certain way it's crazy yeah it's crazy
I'm not even gonna say like we're not
even gonna speak on kid I don't when it
comes to coaches dog like I'm not even
gonna go there and you've done enough so
your reaction when a bee got there you
were excited obviously right then Mayock
tells you Gruden air
anything to you yeah actually I went by
like they didn't know you just tell me
to but I went by like I wanted to talk
to him and say oh no and no not even
like I just wanted to believe it
professionally I didn't even say that I
was upset or anything like that I was
like hey nice move down the line like
you know a nice plant whatever you know
I'm saying just wanted to say goodbye
you know what I mean like maybe we'll be
working together in the future you never
never know in the NFL so can they go
over a wall it was kind of like I think
he did I think you did I don't know he
was very surprised that I did I don't
know like I think it went over really
well but it was just kind of like I
don't know they were surprised for sure
that I that I came by to talk to him I
loved that you know it's like it's sort
of like not just face me to my face like
I'm not I'm not gonna bring any negative
energy I'm not gonna be angry I just
want to see your I'm the funniest thing
is like going in there and like the
security dude meeting you in the front
like what stuff out of my locker my dog
and also say goodbye and freak out were
you offended that they only got back a
fifth round pick
I'd even check up on that after that
sideways soon as I heard that I got
trade I was offended for you yeah I was
offended for you as soon as I as soon as
I like got that but got the trade or
whatever information like it was just
wrong as long as the check clears
yeah actually there was a Janet I still
leave at like 10 11 some nights like on
a Friday night just like whatever bored
I'm gonna work out cuz I'm weird like
that I like to work out I like to lift
weights and there's a janitor that
actually said that cuz I asked him how
he was doing
yeah you good brother how you doing is
he like tired he's a man as long you
know what they say as long as that chick
Cruz no for real Khalil traded Amar'e
traded I mean and then you like I have
to imagine the guys back there right now
are kind of like who's next
it has to be there yeah that's exactly
what Gabe's even Rodney joked about that
like
yeah man I mean like we have like these
professionals that we work with or
whatever like shrinks and even a shrink
teams rings like a man like there's a
lot of people talking to us right now
they're very concerned about I'm like
yeah shrinks are talking to other
shrinks they might replace me crazier
crazyer to be on the team for khalil
being traded or Amar'e Omari was for
clear was just like what but then like
and then it's the stalk but it's so
early still but then like tomorrow was a
slot yo they literally do not care like
because Khalil was before the season and
they got back multiple first-round picks
and he was already holding out really
the first one you're forgetting is Mark
a king like just kind of my opinion like
best putter in the game what's
interesting is he leaves Oakland and
right now he's actually meeting with the
Texans that's exactly what Shane LeClair
did former Raider goes to Houston and
many people believe she and Lecter is
the best putter of all time interesting
thing with special teamers is their
salaries get higher as they get older
and teams are like you know we could
really save $400,000 on the punter this
year by get this kid at a North Dakota
State you know what I mean but so Khalil
there was a track record Amari was that
what week was that that was in the
middle like I felt like I was pretty
deep in the citizenlink in the middle of
the season I remember what week but it
was in the seasons to the point where it
was just like wow and you're aware what
like you're not working out of church
for that are you know we're on the field
at practice we're literally we're
literally already have been through most
of Pratt like grinding Wow you know I
mean and then like they get their little
I don't even know dude's names like some
I don't know some guy whatever grabs him
and we're saying hey like nah like it
was like so unbelievable who would have
been like if alien landed on the field
and was like hey what's up food like
from checklist or whatever yeah yo
that's a Lia it was like that like
goober just shocked like what the hell
is going on right now how did it spread
did they call around the team and say
this just happens like literally you
just like turned around and saw it we
just turned around and saw it you're
just like what oh so you just see him
come off the field but you don't know
why he's coming
no you know because this guy is the guy
that always cuts people who are like
it's always bad when you see this guy
you know it's not good and you're like
so you guys are like they didn't cut him
like the what the what the hell you know
cuz he's a baller you know they didn't
just cut him like he's a baller you know
that he's got balls it was a team just
deflated after that that for sure was
like the dagger like a few times it was
like some situations where it was just
like you know you're on the field and
certain things are getting caught or
whatever and you have no control of that
and they just like do they care whatever
and it's like we're working so hard and
you know and the pain and all of that
people plant their injuries and you're
like what are we doing but then that was
probably like the dagger was just like
wow so the whole team after that moment
you could feel it we could feel it like
people were like talking about it in the
locker room like yeah like I guess like
really like rebuilding like you just
like knew at that point I had a I had a
story I did a story with Malcolm Jenkins
and I'm on his roof and we're getting
ready we had just shot all day about
like bowties and how he's like prepared
for a zombie apocalypse and all that and
it's like a fun time and I get a buzz on
my phone and the Eagles had just traded
Sam Bradford and that meant they were
gonna start Carson Wentz that year and
his face was filled with so much
disappointment because in his mind he
didn't come there to play for a rookie
quarterback he didn't come there to do
the rebuilding because when you're an
athlete your window is not that long
exactly and it's so way different for
coaches with the long tenures and the
guaranteed contracts that they have so
when you're a team and you go we're
rebuilding anyone on that team over the
age of 27 yeah it's like bro not now
dudes are asking for trades like some
guys like I'm just not that type of
person like once I sign on to do
something I finished that but like Bruce
for sure was the guy that was just like
I'm not doing yeah exactly like his wife
stare whatever so yeah you know from
there to what was like to have Marshawn
Lynch on your team that was dope he kept
it to real like we had the realest
conversations on the plane to the point
we were like coaches would come get the
rookies so that they would not have to
hear what he was saying just so they can
keep them like this
you know I can't even all you want to
repeat it I'm scared to repeat it am I
gonna say it what's it about football
was about was about football but it was
also about life too
yeah and like what's going on with foot
I might even go get he sees through the
games you know what I mean and he's the
kind of sod early to like I need cross
yeah that's what's so funny is on a team
that had that much turmoil and changed
to have the ultimate truth teller in the
locker room I just feel like at all
times he would've been like hammy what
the [ __ ] are we like a meetings like I
just feel like he would do that all the
occasional II occasional occasionally he
would not only wasn't I don't want [ __ ]
wasn't suited he wasn't very like he
wasn't disruptive or anything like that
but like privately it's like where he
was like basically late look you know
this is the deal here's the facts yeah
if somebody were to call you whether
it's Cleland Farrell therefore
throughout their fourth pick in the
draft or another guy and they said
what's Gruden like what would you tell
him um you know what he's a passionate
guy he's a passionate guy he loves the
game he's gonna get up at 4:00 in the
morning you know what I mean and and
start coaching you know what but it's I
really don't I really don't know like I
felt like I knew hmm no I really don't I
really don't know so you'd say I was
with him for a year and I still don't
know what he's like I don't know I don't
really know I know parts of what he's
like but I can't say that I really know
what he's like can I ask you an awkward
question because it's been one of the
things I've been most fascinated by
Monday Night Football
Raiders Washington all the stories that
came out is there any truth to that [ __ ]
it's 100 percent false 100 cent false
yeah so if you really want to know what
happened obviously we had heard what
charm said right and clearly there's a
lot of guys it's just like right here
that felt a certain type of how could
you not and so we're like man like we
got to do like some type of display
something weren't even that big of a
deal like it was literally like hey like
you know we're gonna sit whatever we're
not gonna even make a huge deal out of
it and like alright cool
and then it was just what he came out
and saw which is I'm like a bunch of
people were like
oh I basically don't do that like just
stay in the locker room or like whatever
it was right and it wasn't even to the
point where people were like distracted
it was literally hey we're just gonna do
this one thing and then it was just like
a weird thing we're like there were
certain players that were like no like
we shouldn't do that whatever Wow but
it's just like man like that's like
three all saying that we shouldn't do
that and a lot of us feel a certain type
of way so it was kind of messed up but
right three people would be like gnar
like basically make us feel like we're
in the wrong for like and to have this
kind of 308 right before a game yeah but
it was like the night before though like
it was like the day before whatever yeah
by the time game day came around like
most of us were just like hey like this
is how he feels okay this is what we are
going to do yeah y'all like do what I
have to do but we feel this way about
this right now you're the only all-black
offensive line in the entire NFL the
entire energy how could you not how
could it not like him like yours I don't
understand how you can understand that
this was when he came out and said half
the NFL players or he didn't say pieces
of [ __ ] sons of [ __ ]
yeah because the rumors were about
Derrick and I just wasn't just super
full like we all mess with them yeah
like he's funny he's not one of those
quarterbacks that's like super super
serious all a tune oh no man it's like
one of those little media things like a
little troll out there said some crazy
stuff for a little like Derrick oh yeah
one of the media person was like oh this
is why that happened last on today
what's going on and be like way off I
gotta wait for it it is interesting how
they've dealt with Derrick because it's
I hear people all the time like I can't
tell if they like him earth they don't
and that's like players and [ __ ] like
them players like them I have not met a
player that has the doesn't like deers
like that's 100% false that people don't
like Derrick as far as players are
concerned the people that actually know
him you have to like him he's too good
of a guy not to like yeah like there's
never any box for them everybody like
yeah you just have to like have you met
him like if you meet him you're gonna
love him good energy
his dad like his whole family you're
just a great family he's just a great
guy interesting it's crazy it's like
you're not allowed to address it like
you're taught not to like oh you don't
make any comments about this or focus on
this easily often you just want to just
squash it but they're like don't talk to
any media about that man are you happy
to be gone like this like it's not like
not a disrespect to them yeah but I'm
just glad that I'm not dealing with all
that anymore I just want to play
football bro
yeah period you're getting right like
you like the same thing when you're raw
or whatever and how that can take away
from the energy I'm just trying to play
ball like you know what I mean so and
you've now is this like the best
health-wise you've been in a long time
like getting in shape like doing keto
and intermittent fasting and all that
stuff yeah you can feel it yeah well how
different does your body feel right well
I took a lot of weight off my joint so I
mean obviously my knees and my back feel
better
I'm 310 right now and you were what the
last few years
325 Rd and we don't think that's gonna
mess up your power at all I'm the
strongest I've ever been man about to
justice you know I mean our strength
coach yeah yeah like we got a real win
bro like we gotta we have a real
strength coach you know saying I'm not
gonna say anything about the last one
but this dude is raw like this guy's raw
you're just feeling like is it different
exercises to is way different on to what
the hell we were doing well I saw your
seasoned weight room in that we're in
the training camp is it's like a high
school in Oakland like I don't know what
this looks like the yard has nothing to
do with that because we worked out there
when we were with Joe Gomes in my
opinion like the coldest water on dude
is like working for an astronaut he's
that smart State Department oh he was
the trainer yeah like he was he's the
truth let's do the truth so which in and
obviously that translates like to how we
were 112 games and all that type of
stuff like and then like the guy that we
just had but he's since been fired like
I mean no disrespect like you know a
that was his groom's guy or whatever ya
know but like
I'm just happy that we got a good
straight gun Oh like to me that's so
important like there are certain players
that don't like it like Oh like I can
understand your skill played I want to
get like too big
yes don't wanna run fast but like for
like that position upfront if you're not
training the right way if you're not
also training smart too because there's
a lot of banging up front or you're just
not gonna one make it through the season
into like you're gonna burn out fast
there's gonna be way more injuries and
you can just see just from the amount of
injuries that we had from the one
strengths got to the next how important
that is to actually have a guy that's
coached and has been coaching and has
been learning and has been progressing
with yeah training in the NF it's a high
like high it's a competitive job but you
have to be front trainers one of the
line looks like percent of their job is
learning new techniques 60% of their job
is going out and getting certified and
learning the guys aren't even certified
in the way crazy yeah we had we had a we
had a personal trainer we had literally
a pert one of like the guys that were
returning us as a personal training that
was his qualification he had we
literally had how much more quality you
really can dog cuz then you're the bad
guy like you can't you can't certain
guys we tell certain guys like Lee Smith
was one of our guys he was on the
leadership council so we'll go to the
leadership council and be like breath
and then he'll go back and talk to the
coach Gruden and groom come back we'll
give them a little bit more time and
then it gets kind of pushed back and by
the time to actually do something you're
late yeah and then also the dudes on a
curtain guaranteed contract to so you
think he cares really like he even said
that he was like anyway even if they do
here I mean like dude said that
absolutely in his office because he came
to me and was like what's going on one
of the guys was today and I told him why
they're like really well I mean I guess
it doesn't really matter for you guys
and that's the thing bro is such a bit
of business man like they don't care the
way that we care players just like they
don't care the way that we can I hope
that this staff this case staff cares
and I hope that it you're like damn I
feel like I'm first-year Baltimore all
over again yeah that's what it feels
like that's what it's feeling like yes
yeah and this exciting Jets fans are
gonna love to this man I'm telling you
bro like this strength coach bro like
what's his name justice golly justice
Gallic Gallic khaki al AC alright so if
you want to be jacked
nice yeah 3:07 you were saying
to go up against now Leonard Williams
every day in practice and Quinn and
Williams now like this incoming young
guy do you think you could actually help
teach Quinn in - yeah definite yeah cuz
we've heard about like offensive linemen
teaching offensive linemen what about
you helping it almost is more that way
like I just yeah that's just that's just
yeah that's that's how it works like
especially if it's a smart guy that's
really trying to absorb everything and
really really trying to learn like
that's just how it works he'll come up
to you and ask you why he can't be
obviously because in college he he'd
beat everybody yeah and so like if it's
a smart guy that's not like over
prideful which he seems like he seems
like a really like he's gonna be asking
questions so and you love to see that
like I've heard so many times that when
the first round pick walks in the team
has to be impressed like it's it's
important for the team to go we got
ourselves a good one
have you seen Quinton work yet no I have
I think they show up this weekend but is
that I don't know I don't know if I
would say that honestly that wasn't my
experience in Baltimore at least like I
don't know it's kind of like well you
and cool you know it's weird yeah and
I'm sure they were I'm sure the defense
went Dan that Collette she's a big
[ __ ] and they were like oh cool
Upshaw it's a bit like I'm sure it kind
of amped them up a little bit maybe I
don't know but like they don't really
start saying anything into the pads come
on you know like what they it's it's
that's that sport it's like one of the
last you know well
sports in general it's like one of the
last meritocracies like doesn't matter
how hyped up you are what you say it's
like once guys actually see it and they
experience it and they feel it then it's
alright right yeah cuz you just sliding
around with no pads on and not knowing
how physical you are but if you get into
like a fight early owner you toss
somebody and then everyone's like damn
we got ourselves real exactly we got a
dog what was your welcome like did you
have a play where the other team like
the defense kind of acknowledged it
wasn't like a specific plays it was just
like a series of players during training
camp my rookie year where guys will come
up to my locker laughs and like a man
you gotta chill so
me too you gotta chill dawg and we gonna
read dachi we gonna read to you the red
dot means like the whole defense
watching you next time you done somebody
gonna jump you it kind of say that's
like saying yeah they don't actually do
it but well it's a certain guys if they
can do that's a certain guys but like
yeah but like though like yeah like
they'll come up and they'll be like no
I'm playing man you gonna get us right
bro we're gonna be good this year man
you say at work like that's a good
locker room like yes they're competitive
and they don't like in beat but then
they like joke around and be like all
right so that's a good media note for
everyone listening is if you see rookies
getting complimented right now let's
wait yeah but if after the pads come on
you start seeing rookies getting
complimented you knows it's really [ __ ]
this room yeah even like wide receivers
they don't even need like if ones like
amazing it's so different under the
lights though and it's still different
when you're running across the middle
and could get hit in my it's just like
just different like there's a lot of
guys that are super athletic and make
incredible catches put like under the
pressure of the lights they can't
perform you know I mean that happens
sometimes and there's a lot of guys that
just can't transfer that ability and
just really you just have to be like yo
the same stuff I'm doing what made a
dominant you just got to keep doing it
and not even think about the fact that
you're in the NFL it's just a jersey in
front of you do the same stuff that you
do have you talked to salmon all darn
'old yeah a couple times yeah yeah
okay I'm quarterback yeah I think he's I
think he's gonna be good I think so too
he's my guy alright so I have three
stories that I kind of want to talk
about that are either lessons that we
could have learned lessons people should
have learned and I have a nugget I'm
gonna start off with a nugget coming out
of Dallas camp right now Travis
Frederick apparently looks really good
apparently he's on field running plays
was practically an extra coach last
season and I know just from like looking
at offensive lines Dallas has been one
that you've had to keep your eyes a very
long time and to do to have a good year
last year without him if he is able to
come back I'm personally looking at
Dallas and go and watch the [ __ ] out
because they just drafted Connor
McGovern in the third round to kind of
compete with Connor Williams and provide
insurance
frederik can't play because he had this
this disease that they don't even know
exactly what it is but if he's able I
just think that's something I'm looking
at right now look out for the Cowboys if
he comes back that's just a little
nugget something that we need to learn
er I thought we learned involves one of
your teammates
Le'Veon Bell was not at voluntary camp
and you would have thought that he
insulted everybody's mom in the history
of the world he came out and he said
here's what I'm gonna say when it's time
to play football I have to stick to my
formula that I know that works for me to
be the best player I can be I'm not just
trying to win games I want a ring I want
to desperately show everybody what I can
really do I'll take the heat right now
everybody will forget about that when
January comes so his statement included
this I have a formula I want to win a
Super Bowl I'm gonna perform big this
season and I'll show you around the
playoffs and people were offended by
that they were offended by people like
fired up about people are but they're
going they're going yeah if you care
that much you're gonna be around your
team all along Adam GaSe comes out and
says he was here the first week of
offseason workouts he was we gave him a
lot of good information he's got a good
training regimen to go through he knows
his body so pretty much the coach was
like we gave him the information he's
signing off yeah but every television
I'm watching good morning Falco now I'm
watching good morning football I'm
watching shows on the SPN I watching
shows on NFL Network and all of them are
going I don't know I think you should be
there I think you should prove it to
people Baba it's their bodies and
voluntary workouts well this is what
happens this is every debate on
television they debate the word
voluntary and how it means you don't
have to be there and then some blowhard
comes over the top and goes if you
really give a [ __ ] you'll be there Tom
Brady did not go to training camp last
year Walter Jones never showed up
Fletcher Cox didn't go the year before
and everyone said oh we'll see if both
of those guys won the Superbowl Tom
Brady won last year Fletcher Cox won the
year before Aaron Donald held out last
year
missed everything mmm and one defensive
one defensive player they make a big
phrase what do we need to explain to
people that preservation is just as
important as preparation also like it's
not your [ __ ] body and and I I just
don't understand how we're still having
the same [ __ ] debate all the time
when it's been proven every freaking
year that these camps as long as you're
working out on your own and learning the
playbook
do not matter yeah that's true I just I
don't get it kolache sure that's that's
I wouldn't say that they don't matter if
you're a rookie you got to be there like
we saw it in I feel like there's certain
positions okay
quarterback if you're new to the system
offensive line if you're new to the
system right but there are certain
positions that are so like instinctual
like running back that it's like come on
defensive line line like it's just
you're just breaking on know what
direction to go hit though do your thing
know to protect and protections yes yeah
uh levy on I saw a quote from you that
said he's busting his ass right now
yeah he's grinding yeah yeah what's that
like to see it's it's it's good like
he's he's working I can't wait to see
like input it's gonna be dangerous like
the way he's working to see him put on
pads and carry the rock like tote the
rock it's gonna be dangerous if he I'm I
love rooting for guys to prove a lot of
people wrong and I'm one of the few that
think that what levian did contract wise
was a smart move
oh we held out he didn't get that much
more he got a lot more in guaranteed and
also he got a year off with his body
like think about Marshawn coming back
like dude felt amazing great explosive
you can't you can't even tell like how
old he was like you know like all they
were young rookies like how you moving
like that like cuz he had a year off
exactly like that's huge do you think
it's more important at the running back
position or is it valuable for any
position it's valuable for a lot of
positions like offensive wanna be a
position where there's a lot of
yeah for sure running back they get all
the time yeah exactly they get hit as
much as this if they're getting a bump
again hit and blocking yeah exactly yeah
yeah so yeah it's I'm excited I just I
think it's cool that people are gonna
question levy on and he could come back
more well rested with a better offensive
line now with like you there and I I've
liked a lot of the additions you guys
have made this year yo Harrison's gonna
be a dog yeah talk about that so he was
like my Merc workout partner for strain
it's this thing like this it's a crazy
workout justice' psycho but like like
we'd like compete or whatever like we're
like in the same workout group the whole
line me once there's like a lot of us
like compete yeah just the way that he
works out let ik he is and he's
intelligent the questions that he asks
like he's gonna be like under the one of
those under the radar I get old is he
do you news I think he's I don't know
he's young though he's a he's a younger
guy from what ads were from talking to
the guys like in the locker today they
were saying Jonathan Harrison Harrison
yeah from what guys was saying like this
they said he should have started last
year from what guys are saying they're
like have been the guy last year well I
watched some of the snaps and that Miami
game you probably don't see that with
the Jets they needed a center so if it's
a guy that's awesome I can't wait to see
him play bro I'm excited from what I've
seen I can't that's one guy that I'm
excited to see but I thought the signing
of Jameson Crowder was great like a guy
over the middle for a quarterback like
San that looks over the middle
Le'Veon Bell CJ Mosley seeds is a good
such a dog you did not cross over with
him in Baltimore no I did yeah we were
in but somewhere together for like a
year was it 2 or 1 definitely for at
least a year did you pitch him out all
the Jets or did he just he was already
know I didn't pitch them I didn't pitch
them at all that's also though it's got
to be great to see your team sign guys
like that it's its dumbest Peschel ii
when you know it's a good player like
you you know yeah yeah yeah like I see I
seen him work like I know how he like
moves like I know what he can do like
the last lesson that I had is a lesson
that I think we can all learn
Sean McVeigh came out a favorite coach
right now in the NFL
and said that he [ __ ] up and that he
actually over analyzed the Patriots and
what's funny in our culture right now is
people see headlines and they make jokes
but they don't read articles so the joke
was oh I overanalyze
Sean McVeigh came out and this was a
Sports Illustrated article and said he
watched every game the Patriots play
last season including the playoffs and
there are two most recent Super Bowl
appearances and apparently when he said
the last part he shook his head and he
was like really upset with himself he
said that he watched 20 games in that
two-week period to get ready and his
quote was you see stuff that worked in
Week three but you forget that so much
has changed since we you can watch so
much film that you lose perspective
that's not good yeah that's accurate
though like I feel like coaches usually
I mean they'll watch all of it but then
like I feel like they'll just they won't
really go in depth unless it's like the
last four games you definitely I feel
like it's not common to go to other
Super Bowls and stuff like that and
watch the film like you want to see how
they're playing teams and how the team
is progressing and what their tendencies
are within like the last I don't know
like five or six weeks there because
that really gives you like there's
different guys in the year before and
the year before there's not even the
same players are gonna evaluate that so
like I can't see that because you're
taking time away from actually looking
at what they are now I think the the the
thing is one that's the power of
Belichick is he's gonna he's gonna make
you go maybe they're in Super Bowl in
2001 that he might bring back and I want
my team to be prepared but the thing
that I think that we can all learn from
this is make the main thing the main
thing in everybody's life you can get
caught up in the [ __ ] oh I got a
respond to these tweets oh yeah I gotta
go get lunch but if you're not focusing
on the most important thing you're going
to take a step back because you're
taking time away from it and I think
that's what I took away from Sean
McVeigh saying that is in everybody's
life don't get caught up in all the
[ __ ] there's a reason that Mark
Zuckerberg wears the same thing every
day because he doesn't want to focus on
that he wants to focus on the main thing
and if you can keep yourself focused
whether you're a job whether you're in
school whether you're young
like this is a lesson I think we can all
learn whether it's with your family and
not getting caught up in [ __ ] and oh
what happened to a year ago it doesn't
matter where are you now I just think
that's a lesson that we can all take and
kind of go focus on the main [ __ ] do
what you do great focus on what you do
and and and how do you make that better
and the things that you aren't that
great at how can you minimize that and
then do that stop focusing on what other
people are doing because that that will
get you caught up in a whole lot of
terrible it's a terrible I think he
realizes for disaster you don't want to
be too worried about anybody else you
need to focus on yourself you know you
got to be present in the moment and take
care of business and percent uh I was
gonna wrap up now if there's anything
else that you want to talk about or any
questions I will open the floor for a
little bit cuz I don't want this to all
be me asking you questions you know what
I mean let's talk about music man who
you listening to Anderson PAC okay
that's my [ __ ]
no dude out of fishing out of Chicago
okay check him out it's like a Chicago
Renaissance going on right now
really yeah you gotta check that sound
Sabha pivot also Darren Falana dropping
knowledge on Nigerian guy I love cold
out of Toronto I don't know how this
dude isn't big right now dude like I
want that so we have some musical
recommendations right here the
Anderson's my guy like I've I was so
happy that he got to do an actual album
for him dr. Dre produced his little
album before this one and it sounded
like a Dre album and I was like I loved
it it was great I love you it was great
but this last one is so much more him
and that's the [ __ ] cuz he's a nut he's
like express himself he's an artist I
appreciate you coming into doing this
welcome to New York we're gonna hang out
in New York my fiance's literally
calling me not now we'll get a drink
we'll get some dumplings yeah let's do
it
you're the man let's drop that beat
again to walk them off if you want I
might drop a freestyle I think I might
actually start doing like a left
hey thank you it's my birthday
doing it in the worst way he's [ __ ]
Wednesday no it's not a Thursday if you
want to do this shape man we can go and
just jump but man is about to go
downtown and get a dump and if it hits
him right he's going to take a dump and
I don't really give a [ __ ] I bust out of
the slump hold on let me hit it a little
bit more and I'ma see some [ __ ] and get
your mind on the floor because when you
come on the left go show it's never a
bore and if you come in you don't know
what's in store so let me toss it over
to mr. ko he's gonna do this [ __ ] with
the man Adam left oh I need to stop and
quit it [ __ ] hit it you know
you're gonna do it cuz I just did it
alright I gotta do it cuz you just did
it we're on the Adam left coast show so
let's just get it this off the dome no
straight up in your home no hit that
note like a [ __ ] hot little tip
histogram No oh no I almost fell off but
I remembered I'm Kay old man sitting on
the throne on the top they trying to
fight me for the number1 spot but it's
cool I just do my thing you already know
I'm from the south side Maine with them
things bang a town boy you already know
Lana players in the pants man let me
walk with a [ __ ] limp maybe put a dip
in my [ __ ] lip you know I do this
[ __ ] all day I don't even place at the
Alizee now I'm feeling good man let's
Emily hit him up on social what's your
Twitter ko7 zero spelled out what's your
Instagram staying sane
hit him up let him know he's the [ __ ]
man you guys are the [ __ ] homies 33
percent I respect you I love you to live
your life the best you can and don't
worry about none of the haters cuz none
of that [ __ ] matters
Lucas learn you man focus on you make
the main thing the main thing how about
you guys
[Music]